[Music]
On June 3rd 1982 at 2:05 p.m. a girl
named Nia was thought of for the very
first time she had no body no brain and
no name she was nothing more than a
faint red line on a pregnancy test a
symbol of a potential person On January
22nd 1983 after it was determined that
she was a girl her parents decided what
to name her and Nia was officially
thought of for the first time with the
name Nia about three months later Nia
was seen for the very first time without
a screen awoken to the stark light of
the hospital delivery room Nia had no
idea where she was or who she was she
was for this one brief fleeting moment a
completely blank slate nobody and
somebody at the same time free to be
whoever she could on June 1st 1988 Nia
was thought of as a friend for the first
time after her mother's friend's
daughter Sarah asked Nia if she liked
the TV show Danger Mouse
Nia said yes even though she didn't know
what Sarah was talking about being five
years old and the ADATA was better to
say yes and not seem different
Sarah liked Nia because of this and they
hung out every week and watched the show
together Nia didn't really like the show
she liked that sarah liked her though so
she never said anything on March 9th
1991 Nia was thought of as annoying and
weird for the first time after dancing
by herself during second-grade recess a
group of her classmates mocked her and
one girl told her that she was weird Nia
didn't dance again for several years on
October 14th 1994 Nia was thought of as
attractive for the first time after a
boy named Sam met her at school and like
the way her hair looked on one of the
rare days that Nia Ward down
he told Nia that he liked her and
thought her hair was pretty Nia wore her
hair down almost every day after even
though she kind of liked it more in a
ponytail on August 16th 1997 Nia was
hated for the first time after breaking
up with her first real boyfriend Tim Tim
told Nia she was a horrible
inconsiderate person who only cared
about herself
Nia worried that maybe he was right and
got back together with them to prove
that he wasn't
not long after getting back together Tim
broke up with Nia on June 29th 2005 Nia
was thought of as a full-time employee
for the first time
after being hired as a financial analyst
at a large media company it seemed to
make her dad really happy when she first
considered Business and Finance as a
major in college so she stuck with it
hoping it would continue to impress him
and other people she knew and might know
in the future she never really came
around to liking it herself on April
10th 2012 Nia was thought of for the
first time as a wife
after marrying her 7th boyfriend James
she wasn't sure if she was ready when
James proposed but didn't want to hurt
him deeply feared the possibility of
being thought of as old and alone
especially after her mother repeatedly
hinted at the idea on October 22nd 2016
Nia was thought of as a mother for the
first time as her firstborn child Katie
uttered the word mom as she looked up at
new Katie knew nothing about Nia yet but
saw the source of all comfort and safety
and love in his eyes on December 8th
2019 Nia was thought of as a boss for
the first time after being promoted to
corporate financial manager at a major
multinational clothing corporation Nia
wasn't sure if she wanted the position
and hated the idea of bossing people
around but she wanted her parents and
friends and strangers she might talk
with to think of her as a success
moreover she wanted her legacy to have
some significance for her children and
her children's children to look back at
her and think of her as someone who was
someone someone who was important she
took a job and stayed in it for the rest
of her career during her time she helped
make some of the largest acquisitions
and mergers in the company's history
helping it reach a new height in the
industry and popular culture this made
me a quite wealthy and sought-after she
hated what the expectations made her
become though she became somewhat cold
and forceful to her employees and hyper
focused on money and work giving up
almost all of her free time and things
for herself outside of work on August
22nd 2035 Nia was thought of in a way
that somewhat resembled the way Nia
thought of herself for the first time
one year earlier
Nia was diagnosed with the disease known
as cystic fibrosis in an unusual rare
case of a late stage diagnosis the
doctor told Nia she potentially only had
a year or two left
as time passed Nia began to care less
and less about everything she began to
uncover and reveal her deeply withheld
insecurities and
years in character traits as they began
to fill with the air of insignificance
and triviality while in the hospital
during one of the last few coherent
conversations she ever had she told her
husband James that she never truly felt
like herself around him or anyone for
that matter that she had spent most of
her life accommodating other people's
perceptions of her as if her concern was
always about how she was experienced in
the minds of others and never about how
she was experienced in her own how she
wanted so badly to be liked and
remembered by everyone as competent and
beautiful and agreeable and happy and
perfect and successful and now she was
about to die without ever really being
known by anyone at all as nia revealed
more and more to James for a brief
moment for the first time in her whole
life
Nia was thought of in the same way she
was thinking of herself
synchronized perfectly inside her and
James's mind in this moment of
unexceptional naked candor James in Nia
felt the love and boundlessness unlike
anything they had ever before in
Everwood thereafter three months later
Nia was thought of for the first time as
someone who was dead everyone she knew
attended her funeral some of her closest
friends and family members set
incredible things about her at the
service how beautiful she was how sweet
and kind she was to everyone how
hard-working and successful she was a
couple people secretly thought about how
they didn't really like her or care
about her all that much and just one of
the service to be over so they could go
home Nia didn't know what anyone thought
or said she was dead on March 5th 2051
Nia was Dada for the first time as a
grandma her second child Nick showed his
first son Tyler a photo of Nia in a
family photo album this was my mom Nick
told Tyler as he pointed to her photo
she would be your grandma can you say
grandma Tyler just four years old looked
at the photo and let out a soft my
grandma leaving out a letter or two but
understanding what he meant the wrinkles
in Nia's face in the photo made Tyler
laugh a little then Nick flipped the
page to a different photo of someone
else on December 30th
21:07 Nia was thought of for the last
time by someone who ever personally knew
as Katie Nia's last surviving child died
the last clear real memory of Nia
dissolved with Katie's mind
On January 2nd 2372 at 350 2 p.m.
Nia was thought of for the last time
ever her only remaining photos and
information held in a data server at an
ancestry company for people to learn
about their family heritage a young man
named saunas employed by the company was
instructed that day to clear out all
data servers containing unused full
profiles more than 200 years old before
deleting them saunas looked through some
of the profiles as he looked at the
photos he wondered who the people were
he wondered what life must have been
like for them he stopped on one
particular photo it was Nia
he thought she looked really friendly
and happy she had a smile that seemed
completely genuine as if she spent her
whole life practicing it then he toggled
to the next profile within the hour
saunas had cleared the server with one
delete key all traces of Nia were gone
forever
later that night while trying to fall
asleep saunas wondered without thinking
about anyone specific if any of the
people that he deleted would have lived
differently if they thought about the
fact that one day they wouldn't be
thought about at all this thought sent a
strange sensation down saunas his entire
body then he thought about his big
presentation at work he had in two days
that he had been cripplingly worried
about for the last month he suddenly
wasn't that nervous about it he felt a
little moment of freedom and peace then
he fell asleep
[Music]
you
[Music]